foreign
Ville South Carolina hey Drew what's up
hey thanks for having me on sure how can
we help yeah so I currently have
um student loans so I just graduated uh
undergrad in Spring of 2021 and I went
to a full-time job right after about a
week after and then I started grad
school last August which is a two-year
program so I've accumulated uh pretty
much a good bid in student loans about
90 90 000 total by the end of my grad
school career
so I'm trying to figure out you know
what's the best way to attack that
um amount as quickly as possible because
my goal is to be financially free and
debt free as quick as possible so
um and then one more thing is my current
employer found out they have a tuition
assistance program so that's they're
going to knock off about 30 grand right
there so really I'm looking about 60
000.
um
so trying to figure out the best way to
uh you know pay that off as quickly as
possible what do you make
uh about 70
000 okay what's the uh what are you uh
studying in grad school
uh and it's a masters of Engineering
Management okay
and what's that costing
it's costing 60 Grand
and you're how far into it
uh I finished one year so I have one
more year left
okay
what does that increase your income by
for having that
um I'm hoping you know
the company I'm at
um I'm not really sure what the pay
structure is for our management role
because currently I'm in a technical
role
um
I would have to guess I mean about
minimum 90 to 100 starting as a manager
oh and you make what now
70. oh yeah okay but you're guessing
number one so go find out number two uh
you know if you're an engineer and you
busted on a technical level am I
incorrectly presuming that you'd have an
opportunity to move into management or
do you have to have a master's degree to
get into management level of Engineers
um I I don't I don't think it's
necessary to have one I think it it
accelerates the timeline
um it kind of pushes you a little bit
quicker up the up the chain from what I
what I've heard from people at the
company okay
all right uh well you're you're halfway
there you're gonna finish it so the way
you get out of student loan debt is you
live on nothing
and a beans and rice Russian beans you
don't go inside a restaurant unless
you're working there as an extra job and
you don't go on vacation you live on
beans and rice rice and beans and you
attack the student loan debt as fast as
possible you got sixty thousand to pay
off while making 70 towards a hundred
um so I you know you need to do that in
a maximum of two years 2500 a month
2500 a month and you start that now
because you're currently 1970.
and not take on the debt
yeah
um and then the other thing that didn't
sound real convincing
well I also just bought a house too I
was renting about a uh early this year
but I think that was a huge mistake
really you're broken ninety thousand
dollars in debt
yeah okay
um well I I don't know my thought
process was I mean I'm starting to build
equity early
um listen here's the thing okay
um you're gonna have to decide which
thing you're gonna do
and the thing you're gonna do if you
believe the shortest distance to
becoming wealthy which we do and we have
data to actually prove it it's not a
theory and we've been doing this for 30
years the shortest distance is to
not add new debt number one and then
number two live on nothing
and clear your debts as fast as you can
because then you will have control of
your most powerful wealth building tool
um
and quit using your own analysis on
these things because your own analysis
sucks
it's what got you where you are
so don't don't look in the mirror again
and say to yourself you know I kind of
reasoned this through not because your
reasoning has caused you problems
it's got you into a mess
and so you don't need to use your
reasoning you need new sets of
information to make this decision if
you're an engineer you built a bridge
the bridge fell
we don't want to use your calculations
again
okay that's not a good it's not it
doesn't build a good bridge and so that
that's where you're setting and
um so uh you know uh
now
thanks for calling we appreciate you
calling in now let's sidestep a second
Ken because
um
uh a sixty thousand dollar degree that
might maybe maybe increase your chances
of that's overpaying it is for Masters
it is and you're right he's halfway
through so might as well but the
approach the reason I ask that question
is I want people to think about this
unless it is the only way meaning there
is no ticket to the dance if you don't
have this higher ed degree then you've
got to think through it and you take a
young man like this who's fresh out of
college he's got to earn it he's got to
pay his dues Dave he's got to crush it
in the now and then as he does a great
job goes above and beyond what his
leaders ask of him to do he shows
himself to be humble in the workplace he
shows himself to be hungry to look for
more opportunities to do what whatever
it is to win he's going to have an
opportunity for leadership regardless of
the Masters Degree take the same person
with a master's degree and they have the
supposed Edge and they're up against a
guy who doesn't have the master's degree
and one is humble and one is hungry and
goes above and beyond what's required of
them leadership will look at that person
unless there's some sort of weird goofy
politics involved and they're going to
promote that person every time well you
can pay 80 000 for an MBA or you can pay
17 000 for an MBA well there's that too
that's exactly so you need to think
about what you're paying and
um once again we just want to underscore
for everyone out there not just that
young guy but for everyone that not all
education is worth what you pay for it
that's correct it does not give you an
Roi a return on investment necessarily
and so if you pay 17 000 more for an MBA
and you pay for it in cash and you
finish and get a master's in business
and that might open up some doors maybe
a little bit but and you might end up
your knowledge base actually might cause
you to make more not really the degree
but
um beware of anyone who tells you
including telling yourself that going
back to school is automatically worth it
at any cost for any degree Because
unless it's permission to play that's
correct it's usually not worth it it
usually doesn't have an Roi that's true
and if you overpay you ensure that it
doesn't have an Roi and one other piece
of advice for Drew Drew Dave gave you a
really good Target and I heard the doubt
in your voice because you've got a
mortgage now uh 2500 a month can be done
with your skill set as an engineer I
would be besides rice and beans uh in
schooling you're looking for extra work
nights weekends engineer type work where
you can make really good money per hour
that would allow you to reach that 40 50
bucks right absolutely he could do that
and now all of a sudden what needs to be
true for him to pay twenty five hundred
dollars a month to knock this out in
that time period it's going to be extra
work he has a skill set that is in great
demand he can find a way to make extra
money yeah
and
the faster you don't have any debt
the faster you start to build wealth
it's correct because your most powerful
wealth building tool is not some kind of
scheme or scam where you try to figure
out a way to trick your way into it
um it's um your most power your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and it's simple when you don't
have it going out in payments and you
put it in the 401K it and in your Roth
IRA it causes you to become wealthy it
really is that stinking something it is
there's only one way to stack money Dave
you got to make it and keep it and and
we we overthink this stuff